du cinéma maintenant avec le retour du
maître incontesté du dessin animé le
japonais miyazaki son nouveau film
inspiré de la petite sirène sort après
demain il s'appelle ponyo sur la falaise
mélange d'artisanat et de technologie
pascal deschamps il a l'air d'un
paisible retraité japonais mais de son
esprit son aîné du shah mutants des
arbres qui parlait des châteaux qui
volent voici le nouveau bébé d'hayao
miyazaki ponyo une drôle de créature mes
filles me poisson rouge
ils coïncident pognon est né d'une mère
ds et d'un père humains elles échappent
un bon jour à la profondeur des océans
et débarque dans la vie de s'impliquer
un gamin aussi solitaire que craquant
c'est ici dans son petit atelier de la
banlieue de tokyo que travail hayao
miyazaki adeptes de l'animation
traditionnelle maître miyazaki peints à
la main les storyboards qu'il apporte
ensuite chaque jour à son équipe
d'animateurs
il leur mine parfois certaines chaînes
ils ne connaissent pas l'histoire mais
il avoue lui-même quelques changé en
cours de route
quand je présente à nouveau projet
j'écris des idées qui me viennent et
après le changement de choses
l'histoire est magnifique comme
d'habitude elle met aux prises la nature
et les hommes une histoire avec laquelle
hayao miyazaki fustige l'inconscience et
la cupidité de ses semblables lui même
tu veux devenir comme ces créatures
aussi s'occuper des abominables
les humains ne font que voler la vie de
la terre moi aussi j'ai été un être
humain autrefois le pognon est un
hommage à l'enfance et à sa capacité
d'émerveillement
avec ce nouveau conte miyazaki le sage
nous offre un petit bijou anti déprime
m